we explaining why I have malaria and why
I'm in a full flop sweat Melissa
McCarthy exposing the realities of
Hollywood by revealing the worst part of
filming Gilmore Girls I'm gonna cry no
okay
yeah the show set in the fictional town
of Stars Hollow Connecticut was actually
filmed at the Warner Brothers lot in
Sunny Los Angeles sometimes we were like
crammed into small things with coats on
but it was actually like 112 degrees in
Burbank
Connecticut and sometimes those
conditions
and when we did our first poster someone
passed out like just out cold because we
were all in coats like trying to look
blustery and we were just like in a foot
like like sweat sweat like sweating
weird places and you're like look cold
you have to show the gets on and then
you can show that maybe we'll get a good
season out of it and then you find
yourself in year seven you just kind of
think
well it's just nuts you can't even that
wasn't even in the planning because you
can't you just don't think that far
ahead so it's just been great
Melissa played Suki Saint James in 135
episodes over the course of Seven
Seasons it's so so positive like people
are really excited about the show she
returned for a brief cameo in 2016
sequel series a year in the life yet the
cops thought that I had broken into our
house why well when they asked me if I
had broken into it I said yes it was so
fun to go back to that it was really fun
to see everybody again and it felt like
I
I think it was even more sentimental to
me and nostalgic than I thought it would
be like to see some of those sets and to
have all of us back there in that world
again felt really lovely
yeah it was It was kind of it was really
terrific despite her long run on the
show Melissa revealed she's only seen
one episode The Pilot I'm also always
afraid somehow I'm I'm something's gonna
happen and I'm going to be found in a
room watching my own thing so I I have a
super paranoid but like I can't I can't
watch my own stuff in the house for some
reason I'm always like what if I pass
out and paramedics come in and the
takeaway is like she was watching her
own stuff pretty weird and that list of
stuff Melissa doesn't want to watch just
keeps growing she's been booked and busy
in her time since Gilmore most recently
bringing Ursula to the big screen in
Disney's live action The Little Mermaid
the sea witch what has your father told
you about me
you like to stop trouble
I'm only here to help just that she's
such a broad but she's also a stunted
you know
more person by the time I really started
to put her together
is a real 3D
per character I I fell so in love with
her I felt such empathy for her I also
knew she does lots of bad things
foreign